this workshop is part of our
repair and ongoing exhibition by hans
tang studio
at the national design center which
presents a counterpoint in the modern
consumerist culture where repair is
either deprecated
or ironically deemed extravagant through
the exhibition and also today's workshop
we hope to shift the concept of repair
away from near restoration
and to get you to re-imagine the role of
repair as an inspire
inspiring activity that produces
aspiring outcomes
and with that i'll hand the time to aung
lawwey and martin chen
who will be our instructor instructors
for today so
lauren melvin over to you
hey good morning everyone so i'm marvin
and this is laura
so thank you for coming here today for
this workshop
so uh before we start maybe we just talk
about the project a little bit so
our project is called canvas and it's a
it's a
shoe repair kit that we have created and
it makes use of a liquid rubber pin to
repair shoe holes that people get
through like wear and tear so
with that we will start to proceed with
the repair of the shoes
so laura will begin to move into
position to demonstrate the repair
and i hope that you'll enjoy the
workshop
okay so just to check that everyone has
their
shoes with them or like their object
computer
issue so
could be it will also be great if
your can on your camera so we can also
guide you along and see
how your repair process of the shoe is
and if there's anything that you can
look out for as well
yeah so if uh you can also start to
prepare a
repair area for you so for us we have a
we have a cutting mat to prevent our
table to keep our table like clean
so for you maybe you can have some
newspaper or anything to lay on the
table so
to pretend uh to prevent any like pain
from
touching your tables yeah for now
we will continue so uh as you can see on
the screen right now
low way is holding up the canvas repair
kit so this is what you should be having
with you as well
and uh so this is the key and so we'll
go through what what
what's included in the kit right now
so um
so firstly we have the two pain bottles
uh
that comes in red and white so later on
you can choose whatever colors you want
to use
for your repair
and next in the kit we have a stack of
stencils
which will guide you later on in
creating shapes and designs on your shoe
and lastly is a wax paper that uh ethan
will tell you how to use so that it
allows for the
repair to be done more properly yeah
so we can go through the stencils as
well
so for the sensors we have a variety of
shapes for you to choose so
as you can see right now uh laura is
holding up the circular stencil
so this is one sensor and
included we have others as well become
which comes in
more rectangular shapes and of different
sizes as well
yep
yeah and we have like a different size
rectangles
okay
okay so uh we can start with the
shoe repair so right now uh
for us we have a pair of shoe here with
with a hole
on the side and so i don't know
how depending on your own shoe there
might be
small holes or varying sizes of hole but
not to worry like the kids should be
able to
repair as long as they're not too big
yeah so uh now
this is our example of our hole
and
awesome uh some of us we have black
color paint
uh we do but for today we actually given
out
these two colors yeah
so
yeah so right now uh we'll go through
the repair process and you can
also repair along with us and and if
there's any questions along the way you
can restart your hands as well
okay so um for repair area
the first thing you want to do is to
trim and
get the area as clean as possible so
that the pin sticks onto the surface
without um any excess like debris but if
yours is
just a tiny hole with not much uh
fraying of
fabric then it's fine yeah
so uh will now cut
and trim the surface yeah
so this is just to remove like any fake
ends that
exist on the hole so that the repair
will be uh cleaner
but if you do not need to do this step
you can just uh hold on for now
so it's just streaming a little bit and
okay then the next step is to prepare
the shoe for the
repair so
does the shoe have to be washed so uh
is i think it's up to you but then
[Music]
um
like the the pinch should be able to
hold as long as
it's not being like hand washed too
vigorously so uh
yeah but it depends on your own
preference or your state of the shoe as
well
yeah okay so now
uh what we will begin to do is to start
the shoe so that
later on that when we repair is the shoe
there will be a much more firm surface
for the paint to
sit on so if you have any like newspaper
around you or
any anything just to stop the shoe for
this repair
uh it'll be great so as you can see uh
well we now begin to stuff the shoe so
this uh
where the wax paper will come in if your
if your shoe hole is very big so what
you can do is
take the wax paper and put it onto your
your
ball of stuffing that you want to place
in the shoe so
this will create a surface for the pin
uh
to rest on if if your shoe pad is really
big yeah but
if your hole is not that big then it's
still fine
so you create something like this where
the vegetable is above and
and now you'll stuff it into the shoe in
a way where the
the surface of the wax paper will be
beneath the hole or your area of repair
okay yeah so now your shoes should have
a service where is more sturdy
okay
then so for the next portion um you'll
be replaying the shoe itself so
right now we will use the stencils to
create design so
it's up to you to create whatever
designs you want but for now
we'll be using one of the sensors
so the the way the sensors work is that
you use the
the outline of it so you can see how uh
law is taking off the sensor now
so it's supposed to surround the area of
repair that
you're doing on your shoe so for us is
here and we'll just put
a sensor around it so you can choose
whatever designs you want
based on the sensor we have given and
whatever shapes that you feel you prefer
yeah so uh one thing you know is that if
your shoe has
um some corners like like hours right
now it would be good to press them down
and so that the sensor really fits onto
the surface properly
yeah so you should stick try to stick
the sensors as neatly as you can onto
the shoe
so that the paint will form a much more
cleaner like circle or whatever shape
that you chose
so we'll give you like some time now and
maybe when you are done
with sticking your sensors uh you can
use the redstone feature in the in the
zoom
and so this is a time where you can just
uh just be creative and
think of how you want to place the
design on your shoe
so the area that will have the pen is
the
area that is surrounded within the
sensor
okay uh so someone asked how long does a
painting
set so uh uh it
oh you're wearing the shoe now okay
uh i think it takes about like
the like for it to
fully dry completely it takes a lot
it'll be safe to
have like at least like around like
three hours but like for the surface to
dry maybe like
30 minutes yeah but i really i
i don't know if you can wear it on this
on right now
yeah but i don't i don't think the paint
will move a lot but if
you are walking around a lot with it
then in my my shift during the drying
process
yeah oh yeah
okay just to check if everyone is ready
or
if if not we
will move on soon yeah
okay yep so uh we'll carry on from now
and
so after you have the sensor placed so
um now we'll demonstrate
to you how we'll repair with the pin uh
so for this part we
uh suggest that everyone watch first how
we do it because
um the pain like
is uh you should try not to touch it as
much as possible so maybe you can
you can see you can see how we do it
first then after on you can do it
yourselves when we give you the time
yeah okay so now uh don't worry we will
repair the shoe with the pin
so first as you can see our bottle tip
um
is it's a flat tip bottle that we have
designed so that
you can cover more area as you repair
yeah so uh
how long is going to do this is uh show
so you have to do this in uh one motion
in
so try not to go over and that that
areas that you
dab the paint over and over again so you
should do it in one shot almost like um
covering a surface so you can see how
low it goes from left to right and
top to bottom as she pins yeah so now
she can do it yeah
and don't be afraid to have a
substantial amount of pain on it
so it should you should you should have
it around like um
one to two mm thickness from the surface
yeah so you do not actually need to
press onto the surface or
or like your like your painting but
rather uh
give it a good amount of pain like do
not be scared because they thought the
pain will dry down as well
yeah so you know a little bit more than
it should but is it is correct
yeah so how lawyer is doing it is that
she'll go through um
the surface layer by layer so that she
don't need to go back and touch like the
previous areas that she have covered
yeah but if you really want if you
really need to uh touch up
a bit you can squeeze on more pain but
try not to touch around because the
surface of the pain um dries pretty
quickly and
is you'll get a cleaner surface if you
don't touch it as much as possible yeah
yeah okay so uh this is a part where
you shouldn't leave it uh too long so
once you are done with the paint you can
peel off the sensor
so how it is doing is um from the bottom
up
yeah so you want to uh
you don't need to rush that quickly but
you want to do it as fast as possible
um the painting and the removing of
stencil so that
the paint doesn't dry onto your sensor
because before you can remove it
yeah so uh as you can see it now
has removed the sensor and we have this
circular shape of paint on the shoe
so uh i don't know if y'all can see but
the pain is
the thickness of the paint is um it's
quite substantial
yeah so it slowly like turns around the
shoe maybe you can see it actually how
thick it is that we have applied yeah
so uh yeah so this is how
um you do the repair and as you leave it
to see it just dry down and
and form the surface
okay yeah so uh y'all can go ahead and
do it
right now um and if anyone has any
questions
you can ask us as well yeah
but idea is you try to do it um one shot
as much as possible and don't don't
spend too much time
thinking yeah
and to peel off the stencil as as fast
as you can as well
uh okay so so us will already suit one
ladder
uh we have tried on one
like that is three four
it will definitely work better on canvas
because it's
a bit more porous kind of material
so as you can see the repair shoe we
have now
so we it's ideal to leave it on
um a flat surface like the paint to be
on a flat surface
as it dries so so that
there will be less movement of the paint
as it dries
uh so as to ask for masking tape as a
stencil material
uh yeah actually as long as
the tape sticks well to the surface it
will work
yeah but it's just that we have designed
these sensors
in in these shapes so that if people
want to do like
circular designs and all that you can do
as well but actually any thing that
sticks on the surface will work
okay when you're using the
masking tape as a material
it you also have to know unlike the area
that you cover so if it's
if it's too heat with some area then you
might not be able to
do it fast enough where the sensor the
paint won't dry on the stencil
so it's just to take note yeah but
yeah but yeah open to do like any
designs you want
okay so uh let's check some are done
okay so catching us with the pins much
if we combine
two colors uh
i i think it should you should be able
to
just that um don't because the paint
dries up
quite fast so you have to do it when
it's still like
wet yeah
oh see in this
example yeah so uh
someone has tried the two color
yeah okay so uh
just to close up or yeah if anyone has
any more questions
you can uh like final questions you can
ask but also
uh we would like to take a photo with
everyone and their repair products so
it'd be great if you can on your cameras
and uh yeah you can just take a photo of
the repair together
as a workshop
yes
okay uh we'll give everyone like 10 more
seconds if you're
still owning your camera yeah if not
we'll
take that photo soon
yeah no problem jim okay
okay
so we take a screenshot now three
two one
okay
can we ask any pain over the spot
uh you mean like multiple layers or like
okay okay like it's fully dry uh you can
do that but uh
you should ideally do it when the the
bottom layer has
fully dried out so that it cost me yeah
because
if you need to paste stencils or
anything then uh you need a dry surface
yeah okay so if let's see i think we'll
end
the workshop here yeah
okay thank you thank you everyone for
coming and joining us for this workshop
and uh for now i cannot hand the to
so thank you so much laurie and marvin
and before we go
um we really appreciate it if you could
complete a simple survey for this
workshop to help us improve on our
future programs
you can do so by scanning the qr code
you see on the
left and if you'd like to find out more
about the programs that the national
design center has lined up under the
theme of sustainability
and design do scan the qr code that you
see on the right
and with that we end the session for
today thank you once again lori and
marzin and to all of you for spending
your morning with
us and if you have not if you have not
already done so do head down to national
design center to check out the r4 repair
exhibition before it ends on 6th
february have a great rest of the day
everyone
thank you bye
okay hi everyone um i'm shayna and uh
i'm family yeah so uh missing puzzle
piece
repair kit yeah so finally we'll now go
over to
prepare and like just a quick
introduction of our repair kit
um to us we saw repairs like the
opposite of replacement and
instead it can be used to embrace the
objects flaws as well as opening up
opportunities for different definitions
of beauty and perfection
and this like inspired us to come up
with this specific method of repair
so before we begin we just want to check
that you guys have all the tools
all the relevant tools so firstly um
maybe you guys can bring out your
toolkits
yeah okay
so um okay nice
okay your kids should consist of a
shaper toe
which will look something like that and
a stylus
and copper and silver four pieces
and as well as a pair of scissors
and like the most important part like a
puzzle that you
need to fix
okay so um it's up to you if you want to
use like the silver or copper piece so
whichever you think will suit like the
overall aesthetics of your puzzle better
so for us we'll be using the silver one
yeah okay so um
we're gonna just start now so firstly
just place the foil over your puzzle
piece
over the missing piece on the puzzle
like like that
and then this is followed by using the
shaper tool to wrap a rough outline over
the missing piece
so this is the tool that you'll be using
and so the shaper tool will be held like
a pen during this process
and um you might require like some
strength on your part so
just like um add on a lot of strength
yeah
and if it feels a bit strenuous to press
the fall you can just
uh check that you're holding the tool
like a pen which will make it easier and
it's very helpful
so you should be holding the tool like a
pen which would be
very easy to
which would be easy to press the file
over
uh the site for pressing would be uh
like you're talking about a tool right
yeah it should look something like that
oh yeah it's the comeback side yeah
once i've gotten a rough outline of the
missing puzzle piece continue to use the
same tool which is the shaper tool
to create more details and depth
so this can be done in a sweeping motion
inwards towards the center
as you can see fondling is doing it now
so this is actually done to pull more
material into the cavity so that the
fall does not tear too easily
uh i think like for this step you can
like take your time to complete because
it's not good to rush the process so you
can like carefully go through
all the edges and be cautious
and we'll just wait for you yeah
because if you do it too quickly you
might tear the piece
so just take your time and slowly do it
like funneling is
so
so if at this step you accidentally tear
the files or you can just uh
take another piece of file because
that's why we have
more than one
if you have any questions you can just
unmute or type in the chat
uh the thickness is like 0.127
mm yeah
if the aluminum foil that you are
talking about is like the one that you
use to wrap your food i think
uh it's not recommended because it's
quite fragile so it will tear very
easily
when you wanna do it so yeah you can
actually get these four from uh art
friend
if you are interested in doing more
i'll show you the packaging towards the
end of the workshop
um hi china i'm hj
yeah uh just wondering what other
things that we can repair using this
method
do you have any idea or yeah
okay that's a good question
[Music]
not really because we feel like this
repair method is very unique to
to the project that we're doing unless
you want to use it to
kind of like emboss other objects as
like decoration but
for now we haven't really thought of
other methods of repair but if you have
any like ideas can just share it as well
yeah
okay so once you're satisfied with the
embossing that you have just completed
you can proceed to use the next tool
which is the stylus
which is also held like a pen to push
outwards
around the corner so um
this step is done to further refine your
refine the corners and the overall shape
so you can do it the same way that
founding is
just rub it around the edges of the
embossed
puzzle piece shape
you can try to get like closer to the
edge so that your
piece will become more refined and nicer
and you can
uh also be careful with the stylus
because uh it's quite sharp
so it might create some holes in the
piece so just do it slowly as well
and if at any point your four p your
five piece does tear you can just
restart again
okay so for those that are finished you
can move on to the next step
for those who are still doing it can
just take your time
then we'll repeat the steps again later
so for this next step you use the
shaper tool to flatten the outer area
which might have caught up during the in
the midst of embossing so
just the peripherals of the embossed
puzzle piece and just flatten it
very easy okay
and once you're done with that you can
just
remove the file from the puzzle and then
you can flip it upside down
so when you flip it upside down you
should have like a
bumped up version of the puzzle piece on
the form
uh then you'll use the stylus also held
like a pen
to run around the outline of the piece
so this is to make sure that the edges
are
really crisp and flat so look nicer
once you cut it out later
okay so i just repeat the same steps
again
just in case some of you missed it out
so
after you're done with uh using the
stylus to
refine the address you will use the
shaper tool
to flatten the peripherals
of the four piece
so just to ensure that because this
um during the midst of embossing in the
previous steps
uh the piece might have caught up so
this is to flatten it
and then once you're done with it you
can remove the file from the puzzle
and then you will flip it upside down
and then you use the stylus
also held like a pen and then run it
around the
outline of the piece to give it like a
very
crisp and flat edge
okay so for those that are done with
this step you can now use the scissors
to cut the piece out so when cutting it
out you can eyeball about two to three
meter
mm spacing so it should look something
like that
so we've actually drawn on the black
outline on the puzzle piece
so um that should be kind of like the
gauge that you'll make when you cut out
your
uh embossed puzzle piece if anyone is
confused can just
uh ask yeah so
we kind of need like a 2 to 3 mm spacing
to ensure that
the puzzle rests on the puzzle
the puzzle piece rests on the puzzle
in a very stable and flat manner so
you can just cut it out like that
alternatively it might be easier for you
to cut out like a larger radius
and slowly trim it such that it becomes
a 2 to 3
mm spacing whichever you think is more
comfortable
and easy for you to cut it out yeah
yeah so now funding will cut along the
black outline which is a two to three mm
spacing
so um just be really careful when you're
cutting it because
the edges can be quite sharp and you may
cut yourself
so for this step uh it's quite normal
for your puzzle piece to bend a little
when you're cutting it but that's fine
you can just uh
bend it back once you're done cutting
so right now finally it's kind of like
trimming the edges
but um if you do it correctly it should
look something like that
if you can see it clearly
okay so um like fongling is really done
with cartoon ring so
it looks something like that i'm gonna
pick it up like um so this is the the
back and then the other way around will
look like that
as well yeah so you should get something
similar to foam links
piece
ah you can stick it back onto the puzzle
if you want to like if you want it to be
more
of like a permanent fix but if not
you can just like um leave it there i
guess
uh hi um waiting i think like um this
repair method
is soft kind of to like um embrace the
flaws in the puzzle which is the
missing piece so it sort of like stands
out
so i i don't think we had the idea of
like using like special
color paint to fit it with the puzzle
piece
but you can if you want to but i'm not
i'm not sure what kind of
uh paint can be used yeah
ah so um if you want to use a glue to
stick to the puzzle i think maybe
something you can try would be super
glue
uh yeah we haven't actually tried it out
but it should work because
um the material should stick together as
well remember you can do like
a test piece first before you
permanently stick it together in case
um it doesn't work yeah
okay so if everyone is done uh it'll be
great if
you can um show your faces then i'll
just take a picture together with like
um
oh our puzzle piece or fixed puzzle
piece
come and see okay yeah um okay so thank
you everyone for coming to
the workshop and waking up so early in
the morning
uh yeah it's only for me
i'll hand the time over to cheryl now to
um end it off but thank you everyone for
coming
hi everyone and thank you for joining us
today for the r for repair e workshop
beetle
so this is the third session out of a
total of four sessions in this series of
workshops
and this is presented as part of the
national design center's program lineup
for january under the theme of
sustainability and design
so i'm felicia from the design singapore
council and i'll just be sharing a
little bit more about the program for
today before we delve into things proper
so this workshop is part of r for repair
an ongoing exhibition by hans turn
studio at the national design center
which presents a counterpoint to the
modern consumerist culture where repair
is either deprecated or ironically
deemed extravagant
through the exhibition and also today's
workshop we hope to shift the concept of
repair away from mere restoration
and get you to re-imagine the role of
repair as an inspiring activity that
produces aspiring outcomes
so with that i'll hand the time over to
cynthia and kakiet who will be our
instructors for today
hello i'm kaki and this is cynthia okay
so today we'll be bringing you through
how to use vido
a repair kit designed for ribs and tears
in bags
just a quick introduction we decided on
a back
back repairs back repairs as bags are
every necessity they don't just store
our belongings but also a daily
companion
upon heavy use the best quality our bags
will be subjected to wear and tear
with bido we are not only repairing bags
also giving our bags new personality and
life
the process of ironing the beads to
catch the damage is simple and every
repair will be very unique
okay so center will be demonstrating the
process while i bring you through the
steps
you're encouraged to turn on your camera
so we can interact with you and keep
track of your progress
okay okay then i'll just move on um
okay we'll start now uh just
just like um take note don't worry about
getting it perfect because every repair
is unique and just like most importantly
remember to have fun
okay so i'll start by introducing the
contents of the bag
so a pack contains two packs of beads
in two different color ways
yeah so this is the first one this is
the second one
so within each like pack of beads it
also comes with two pieces
of baking paper so you can see cynthia
cutting up the
pack now yeah
okay so this is yep the baking paper
and and other than baking paper lastly
we have the sample swatches of how the
finished repair should look like
and just a heads up every repair will
have a unique set of colors so you can
see here center is like the more reddish
and the more nude colors here
but some of y'all might have the clear
colors um so do not worry we're just
trying to switch it out a bit and have
everyone um
yeah everyone will have different colors
and the colorways we gave are
recommended but please feel free to
switch up the color combinations when
you are arranging the colors
you can even mix the colors from two
different packs if you wanted to
yeah so things you should have before we
start
so do take note definitely have a pair
of scissors with you
um ironing board and iron
i'll give you a few and then something
you should also have will definitely
be your back to repair with the rip
and cynthia will take out her bag now
with
a rip
the recommended back materials are their
name cotton polyester
and canvas um ideally also try not to
sit under a fan
as it might make the ironing process
later on a bit more fiddly
and if you are wondering if you can wash
your repair later on
it is is recommended to go um to do like
gentle
washing or hand washing yeah but it's
fine to wash it
okay so this is the the rip that
okay um if everyone has the things they
need i'll proceed on and another thing
to take note importantly is that ironing
must be done by an adult or supervised
child
so if any of you kids are doing it
please remember to
not do the ironing part by yourself but
ask your parents
on a doubt around to help and the beads
are strictly not for consumption
even though they look very colorful okay
yeah um
[Music]
is everyone okay then i will okay
that's great nice okay
so the first step would be to heat up
your iron
cotton setting on medium heat is
generally recommended
so we are heating up the iron a little
bit more early on because it takes a bit
more time so we can
in the meantime we'll do it other stuff
okay
if we are all done with that um we will
now be working
on the ironing board so make sure that
your ironing board is a flat surface
because we'll be placing the beads on it
later on so we don't want any of the
beads to fall off and because they're
quite
small it can be quite fiddly yeah
oh okay
so cynthia just now she has cut open her
pack of beads right
so not right now she's gonna use a pair
of scissors
to cut the baking paper
into a smaller piece if she needed to
match the
the size of the baking paper to rip and
uh
because but if it's but if you're okay
you still don't need to cut
yeah so you place the baking paper below
the rib of the bed
so that the beets will melt through the
hole and
take like the back of your back okay so
um the next step we will be working on
the beads already so with a pair of
scissors
uh you can you can look at the beats we
gave you you can see what colors you
want
and ideally you should cut the beats out
into pairs or individual beats
yeah which you can see what cynthia is
doing now she's like cutting
a column and cutting out two beads
um kind of beads that you think will be
enough to fill the
hole
it might be the beads are quite small so
don't worry take your time
because yes it might be a little hard to
handle
so i think over here synthetic like six
beats is it
okay she's gonna cut a little more than
six speeds
don't worry if you wanna cut a bit more
and yeah and please feel free to
switch up the color ways if you wanted
if you like some other colors from
another
pack please just feel free to use those
as well
okay and then over here you can see that
cynthia
plays the beats over the hole in the
standing up position
and remember to place the beads close
together
like almost as if they're attaching so
your repair will not have any gaps
you can see her packing it together with
her fingers
yep um
it is okay if you all want to cut in
threes as well we just decided on twos
and ones because we wanted a look that
was
a little bit more less neat and stacked
but if y'all
if you're one like a a neat two by three
row of
beads melted together y'all can go ahead
and just cut a two by three
bead stack as well
uh what's the oh so um stella asked
what's the minimum beats needed to uh
to use i think as long as you have
enough you have beads that are covering
the hole and you don't see the hole
anymore
i think that's when you know that it
should be enough
so just depending on the rib entire back
end
i think generally if you want to be safe
it's always better to use more than to
use less
yeah so the next step will be to
carefully place
another piece of baking paper over the
completed
beat design and you can do it um
and make sure that none of the beats
fall
yeah so just place it gently over
just like what cynthia did here
i think cause we will be moving on to
the ironing step
very soon ideally uh i think an adult
can take over from this step onwards
already if a kid is doing this
okay i'll move on to the next step so uh
we will now proceed on to taking uh
taking our iron
and iron over the area like place it
over the beads gently
directly above it and iron over the area
for about one to two minutes
so noting to constantly move the iron
and iron till the beads melt
and merge together it is a clear sign is
than when there are no more holes and
the color becomes more visible through
the baking paper
can you hear you can see that um
cynthia's one is slowly melting already
as you can see the but
the beads have melted with one another
yeah and over here you can choose
whether to melt it thinner by ironing it
for a longer time or if you want a more
3d effect
you can iron it for a shorter period of
time
but do take note that if you iron it too
fat or iron it for too long it may cause
the colors to bleed into one another
yeah so you can just move it around for
a while
and definitely because it will be hot
please do not touch it immediately
this part is definitely the most crucial
step so don't worry about it if you need
more time just let me know
remember to please do not touch the
beads because it will be really really
hot
i think one part that me and cynthia
definitely liked most about this part of
it was
because i i guess when we used polar
beads as kids
we always had them in very like a very
fixed forms and they always give you
templates where you melt them in very
like and then your results are always
quite pic pixelated so i think what
means in the farm was interesting about
this was how the
the when the beads melt they kind of
melt haphazardly into one another and i
think it gave like
color beats this new idea and i thought
it was and we thought that it was
a very nice application to use it on
back repair yeah
so yeah we hope that you like this look
as much as we do
um so we we did do it on bed repair but
you can always use this on um
other other apparels you might have
maybe like a bucket head i think
generally as long as the materials are
along the lines of their name cotton
polyester
and canvas it would be ideal to use
beetle because
um the pack we gave quite a lot of beads
in one pack so
i think you can explore and if you ever
have other um applications you apply it
on like
how can you share it you can yeah
you can share it with us i think i think
by now the
the beats will not be very hot anymore
so we can
slowly peel the parchment paper out and
to review the beats
oh and please take out the baking paper
that we placed inside as well yeah
okay so you can see that cynthia has her
one
and it's really nice
um if you need more time don't worry um
or if you need a
more demonstration to be done since i'll
be working on another one
yeah so we have another plain canvas but
she'll be using a different kind of
camera
and she'll be using a different colorway
other um cynthia also checked
um this the video repackage on her
transport bag like even that kind of
material it worked as well
and she washed it a few times as well
and it didn't yeah and
and it stayed quite well
so she's placing the baking paper below
the beads
and this time she cut the beads in in
pairs
it's easier to handle when you cut it in
like um and more than
one with if you cut at least pairs yeah
instead of
individual beads
slowly iron it over a piece of baking
paper
and nothing to constantly move it around
so it doesn't burn
you can lift it lift your eye now and
then to see how much the beads have
melted
if it melted enough you can normally see
it better through the baking paper
right now you can see that has melted
quite quite a bit already and the colors
have merged together
okay yeah and definitely do not touch it
immediately yeah
you can see that the outcomes for both
of them are really quite different
so with every repair yeah the result
will really be unique
from the way from the colors you choose
and to the way the beats
melt with one another
i think there's a question from
lydia um how to prevent the beets from
dropping off over time
i think one thing that you can prevent
it from
dropping off dropping off over time is
that you can iron it more
and flat um iron it flat like quite flat
so that the the beads and the wax will
melt into the fabric
and bind better to the fabric yeah
we have another question hold on let me
check it out
um
i tried some color beads uh oh oh it's
not question
on a black and white t-shirt to give it
new life loving the effect
it's great i'm glad you like it
um sarah said thanks for a fun session
great to think how to use
these familiar materials in the creative
new way yeah i think that's the part
that me and cynthia was so most excited
about um to see polar beats have this
new look to it
okay if everyone is done then i'll round
off the session
so thank you so much for spending your
early saturday morning with us um we
really hope that you enjoyed the repub
repair process as much as we did and
yeah please feel free to explore where
you want like um
apply these beetle beads at and
just always remember to have fun
okay uh uh if you want
i think it's recommended if y'all turn
on the cameras now so we can all take a
picture with our repairs
well being very nice well there's a lot
[Music]
oh it's really nice
you see that a lot of y'all use the um
the red one that cynthia used as well
yeah oh lydia applied it to like the top
of the handle which is quite interesting
because you've never done that before
yeah yeah that's that's a really
interesting way of using it
okay okay should
oh she did a t-shirt one oh that's
really nice oh she did it on the nose
she did it on the face of the thing
okay that's really cute
okay okay yeah okay everybody smile
you help hold it okay
you can't see okay one two three
okay nice i think another one yeah okay
one two three
okay nice great thank you so much for
joining us
all your repairs look really really
lovely
bye bye
[Music]
so before we start can we check if
everyone has their kid with them
if you do please raise your hand and
those that do not uh please get your kid
ready
yeah in the meantime while today gets
ready
on her side
yeah a point to note too our kit
consists of
a piece with a sharp end so we strongly
recommend
adult supervision and guidance if you
are doing it
doing your repair with children around
yeah so just to be safe yeah all right
so i see that most of y'all have raised
your hands
so okay moving on so each kit should
consist
of a core piece all right we'll start
unpacking here
each kit should consist of a core piece
the center piece
that has a sharp edge connected to a
a foam piece and also nine petals of
different colors
so you don't really need any other tools
for this repair
yeah so uh going through the nine pieces
uh
inside the bag you should have two big
circles
you should have two big circles two
small circles
two even smaller circles
two big semi-circles
and one small semi-circle so
in total you should have nine pieces
with you
if you all have any missing piece uh
please feel free to
raise your hands yeah so for the call
you may choose to remove the styrofoam
protector or not
yep if you have children around i
recommend that you leave it on for now
yeah but if in the case that you do
remove it please be careful to note
not to hurt yourself with the sharp end
of the stud
so because the pieces are designed in
accordance to the golden ratio
the composition should mostly work out
well so anyone is an artist here don't
worry if
you think you you might not know how to
compose something nice but
i'm sure you will we designed the parts
in a way to have
a tight fit so you may hang each full
bloom on the wall without having
any fallen petals so so thus
we will start with planning your
compositions out before piecing them
into the core
yeah so uh looking at the core now
there are four holes each
at the north south east and west of the
core
making up a total of 16 holes so to plan
your compositions
you should have that in mind and
yeah to start off let's plan it on a
flat surface like your table to save the
hassle of taking out the pieces
after you put it into the to the center
piece
so set the pieces as you would around an
imaginary center core in the four
directions so now you'll be
forming your compositions according to
any way you like
so you do not need to use all the pieces
just use the ones
you put colors that match each other or
don't match this up to you
and make sure the joints are at 90
degrees to each other
so just imagine that the center piece
is right smack in the center yeah
so now let's take some time to play
around with the arrangements and
combinations to find out what you like
and once you are done and happy with
your composition
please raise your hands and we will move
on to the next step
uh we encourage you all to turn your
cameras on so
we can like look at each other and uh
share our pieces later on too yup and if
you have any questions
please feel free to ask
all right to repeat uh once you're done
please raise your hands
so that we know that uh you're finished
uh i see that we have a new participant
coming in charmaine
so to catch you up our kit
consists of nine pieces and a
centerpiece
so now we're in the process of arranging
the compositions around the center
yeah so feel free to just play around
with whatever
arrangements you want until it's
satisfactory
all right uh i'll take it that most of
y'all are done give me a second
all right so let's move on to the next
step so the next step is
uh once you are done uh we we are going
to
plan the layout after sorry after
planning the layout we are going to
start building
yep so the kit is designed in a way to
allow you to remove and insert another
piece
if you were to change your mind or
simply want to change the abstract of
your wall plug
but an important thing to the note
because the feeds are so tight
you should refrain from drastically
twisting the piece out in the case that
you want to change the piece
as it may break the connector join so
instead hold the petal
as close as possible to the core like
this right
and slowly pull it out in the opposite
direction of the core very slowly and
gently
so when you do this you might want to
wiggle it out
very slightly just so very slightly but
don't twist too much
yeah so moving on the tip is to start
building from the front row
to the back so we won't have a hard time
trying to slot a battle between two
others later on so to put in the core
pieces
simply push the connector joint through
the hole
this might take a bit of effort as the
holes are tight fit and designed to hold
your compositions on the wall for a very
long time
so yeah slowly push your petal in but
make sure not to twist it
yeah so let's do this right now
form your compositions on the center
piece and take your time
to push it in and be careful not to
break the pieces
and feel free to unmute or chat with us
or drop a message if you have any
questions
yup and lastly raise your hand when
you're done
so we can move on uh to the next step
yep so if with each kit you can create
many different styles
and compositions so once if if you put
your
your your pieces in and you realize that
maybe it's not the composition you want
you can always take them out and then
try it again with another different
piece
uh or another different composition also
if you put it on a wall and like maybe
after six months or so you're bored of
it you can always
just switch up the pieces whenever you
want yeah
okay uh city as you can see she's
playing around with different
compositions
that she thinks it's nice so
feel free to like maybe even reference
how she
is doing it or if you like any of her
compositions really just
you could just copy her or just make
your own we encourage you to make your
own yeah
but yeah let's have fun
acceptance
lydia has a question so hi where do you
get your materials from
so for the acrylic pieces uh that we
just got them from normal
a normal acrylic piece shop and then uh
laser cutted them to size
custom-made and then as for the middle
piece
it was 3d printed made with resin
yeah so that's basically it
so a little behind the motivations of
why we came up with this project
is because uh we wanted everyone to be
able to
play a part of having have a part of
their character
to to build into their house or to
create a piece
that can be part of their home so that
uh to add part of their own personality
inside their home instead of having a
uh we will wait for everyone to finish
before we move on to the next step
yeah so
please wait patiently yes
don't worry are you done
hello
hello how are you have you eaten
breakfast cairo
he made the same one
oh yeah in the set of nine acrylic
pieces there's actually one
that's dichroic color so when you look
at it from different angles
it has different colors yeah so that's
quite interesting by itself
but one tip here is you may want to put
it
away from a solid color backing so that
you can see it clearer
yeah you see like if you put it in front
of a solid color it disappears
so maybe put it in a gap between two
pieces
and there and it will stand up more yep
just a tip
once you're done please raise your hands
but please take your time
all right so point to note
if you haven't identified the hole in
your home it should look something like
this so the hole in your
the hole in the wall of your home uh
we'll need a plastic wall plug inside so
normally when
you drill the wall there's already a
piece inside
or when you remove the piece that was
there before so just leave it in
as it will serve as a support for your
repair piece
yeah okay so
i reckon everyone is done so this is
also another
another example of how you can do it uh
this is a
monochrome set with a little orange
right there so
all right i think uh once you're done
let's get
everyone to show the camera your
beautiful pieces yeah
so you can like see what each each other
has done and also look at your wonderful
arrangements
yeah so it'll be great if you can put it
up into the camera to the camera
all right if you could please turn on
your camera i see everyone likes a lot
of people like pink color
come over here all right
let me just wait for today to come over
then we can take a group picture
all right so let's take a picture in
three two one okay
all right so everyone ready yeah no in a
picture
no i don't okay three
two one
let's go it's three yeah
another one sorry three two one
okay nice oh you all have all very
wonderful pieces
congratulations all right so
uh actually you are almost done so now
the only step
left is to just place it in your wall
yeah just place it in your wall uh
if the wall if the hole in the wall is
too
too small you can try to widen it a
little more first before putting
the piece in yeah uh
and voila your congratulations you have
completed your repair
with a flower that's fully bloomed on
your wall so
thank you we've come to the end so thank
you everyone for coming to our
e-workshop
this morning and we really really hope
you guys had an
enjoyable time with us here today so now
we'll pass the time back to felicia
thank you
all right thank you so much uh to see
and john joe for hosting our last
workshop in this series of hour for
repair e-workshop so before you guys go
i really appreciate it if you complete a
simple survey
to help us improve on our future
programs so you can do so by simply
scanning the qr code that you see on the
left
and if you'd like to find out more about
other programs that the national design
center has lined up you can scan the qr
code
that you see on the right and so with
that we'll end the session for
today thank you once again to everyone
and our instructors for
spending your morning with us and also
if you've not already done so the r4
repair exhibition will be ongoing all
the way to 6th of february so do
drop by to check it out thank you